INSTANCES THE LEGAL TREATMENT.
>> Tucker: STEPHANIE GRISHAM
IS THE PRESS SECRETARY AND JOINS
US TONIGHT TO CLARIFY A POINT
THAT HAS PEOPLE CONFUSED,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
IS IMPEACHMENT GOING ON?
HAS THE PRESIDENT BEEN
IMPEACHED, WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, WHAT IS THIS?
>> IT CONTINUES TO BE A CRAZY
SHAM AND CONTINUES TO BE
SOMETHING I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US UNDERSTAND.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THIS WHOLE
THING IS THAT WHEN NANCY PELOSI
GOES LOW, OUR POLL NUMBERS KEEP
GOING HIGH SO THAT'S A FANTASTIC
THING.
I THINK THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LEADING THIS CRAZY EFFORT ARE
GOING TO GO DOWN IN HISTORY AS
THE PEOPLE WHO WEAPONIZED
IMPEACHMENT AND THIS IS GOING TO
GO ON FOR YEARS AND YEARS TO
COME, OTHER PRESIDENTS CAN NOW
GET IMPEACHED OVER POLICY
DISPUTES.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS, HAS
TO GET IT OVER THERE TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE THE IMPEACHMENT
ISN'T GOING TO BE VALID.
ISN'T GOING TO BE LEGITIMATE IN
THE EYES OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND WHEN IT DOES GO TO THE
SENATE, IT WILL BE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG, THE
PRESIDENT DID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
WRONG.
>> Tucker: BUT AS IT IS IN A
HOLDING PATTERN WHERE IT
REMAINS, IT SEEMS TO BE IF
ANYTHING HELPING THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS REELECTION.
SO ARE YOU ANXIOUS TO GET IT TO
THE SENATE, IS THE STATUS QUO
HURTING YOU, DO YOU THINK?
>> NO, I WOULD SAY THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO GET IT TO
THE SENATE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WANTS IT
TO HAVE THE WORD IMPEACHMENT
ATTACHED TO THE PRESIDENCY AND
HE HAS SAID THAT A FEW TIMES SO
OF COURSE WOULD LIKE IT TO GO TO
THE SENATE SO THAT WE CAN SHOW
THAT HE DID NOTHING WRONG.
WE CAN PUSH BACK ON ALL OF THE
LIES THAT THEY WERE TELLING IN
THE HOUSE I WANT TO SAY THE
IRONY THAT THEY ARE HOLDING
THESE ARTICLES BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT FAIRNESS.
IS IRONIC, HYPOCRISY ABOUND,
CONTINUES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S
THINKING, I THINK SHE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO ACTUALLY.
>> Tucker: I THINK WHAT YOU
JUST SAID IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SHE IS CAUGHT BETWEEN WARRING
FACTIONS AND SHE IS STUCK, I